[Music]
this week we've got family time fail NBA
shocker
oh no and a copy substitute
take it away Tiffany let's part with the
coffee substitute no I don't think we
play that wrong so for family times fail
McDonald's in Singapore installed eiffel
lockers so they all finally they're
doing something good good job Macau yes
they look like this it's part of their
campaign called phone off button on that
is sick I love that they put your phone
when you eat yeah so that's their goal
like they're trying to get family to
spend more time together and like put
away the phone yeah like a survey and
they found like a really high percentage
of families always have their phone outs
when they're eating honey remove that
what a great way to get all the phones
in one place so I could pick that up and
run away with it yeah but a lot of
people were like oh this kind of a fail
because no one is using it oh that sucks
yeah like all of these keys are still in
that's true this is Asia things need to
be forced you can't give people options
that doesn't work out there and Asian
parents don't talk to their kids so
shout out to mom and dad they did give
them a discount percent discount put
your phone away everyone will do it Oh
Dan that's doing a lot though just to
try and like get people to talk to each
other like hey let's lose money so cuz
we care and because of it like they
could be like McDonald saved our family
you know or it could destroy families
like what if the phones were keeping
appeasing everybody I keep him everybody
chill but now you're forced to have a
[ __ ] conversation exactly and I can't
talk for eight all Asian families but at
least the ones that I know and the one
that I grew up in that is always [ __ ]
trying to say some [ __ ]
mom is they're always asking you if you
did this or if you did that it's just a
freaking lecture session and I'm just
sitting there lunch can't we talk about
feelings or something like what's up
dude so it's what's gonna happen is it's
gonna be all these little Asian kids are
like Tron it like Singaporeans kids
trying to eat their cheeseburgers and
their find like that's the only time
their parents talk to the my god every
single time I hear some like a child
parent conversation it's always did you
do your homeland to make sure your room
was clean did you do that today how was
your test grade you know you have to
work hard you know why you have to make
money you know why you have to be rich
you don't want to be poor it's too hard
to talk to your kids I think at that age
though you know what I mean because I
hold no weight from teenagers because
you can't relate to them anymore
I could relate to my parents when I'm
through my 20s mmm cuz then we had
similar experiences right so we're
talking about first love breakups all
you know whatever working a job also the
[ __ ] then you can start relating and
then you know complain together it's
definitely easier when you get old
yeah yeah you can complain about the
same [ __ ] but you can also just have a
simple question and go how was your day
hmm and then what did they have junior
high struggles elementary school
struggles whatever struggles they had or
if they had a good dick to talk about
absolutely but Asian pears will not ask
questions like that's true how was your
day and why'd you ruin it yourself I've
told my mom like after like a day of
coming home and then she's immediately
nagging me about like this and this and
this and I'm like mom can you just can
we just have a regular conversation
before you start going in on me this is
short-circuits like what is regular
conversation just nagging at us
I try not to but it he just doesn't open
up with me at all like he opens up
easier with Casey because I guess it's
like boy knows man you know we bros
before moms yeah
oh nothing like the how is school how
like I always try asking like what you
do during recess because I guess that's
like the most you can't share that stuff
with you some bad stuff is I was looking
at bitch's mom what you want no no he'll
tell me something he does and then I'll
use that I'll think of it as like an
opportunity to teach them something in
the knife fight is to lecturing I can't
do that just my kids [ __ ] dude I'm like
in the world [ __ ] them up instead of
me dude he's blaming on everybody else
he's gonna be his best friend or their
best friend yep yeah exactly do your
homework let's smoke would be that
[ __ ] obnoxiously cool dad there's a
lot of good kids that have those
reckless parents that are like I want to
be your brother I want to be your sister
and then they wish they had a parent
that was responsible and actually a
parent but that's the best way to do it
I think when you stress yourself out
trying to be a good parent you know you
want to reverse it let the kid be the
parent let the kid take care of you and
let them [ __ ]
no I mean like we're kind of like the
ice we have reckless parent said we kind
of like ended up yeah I don't have the
greatest relationship
look at how great you turned out you're
more responsible than your mom you know
that's the way we go do you have a
relationship with your parents or you
have a relationship or you have a good
life it's one or the other right I'm
gonna make my kid's life miserable I'm
gonna purposely divorce whoever wife
like work work work work team work so
that way your kids are like I'm not
gonna be like my parents I'm gonna work
hard that relationship so like me and
Jess we come from a broken home so we're
gonna be out I'm gonna let her know like
look look how great we turned out so we
gotta break the home so they're
motivated about something I dunno am i
doing this like your kids come from
school right and they're about to turn
the corner you just gonna
[Music]
yeah we gotta keep our action flashes
we're gonna take acting classes all
stunts
yeah but makeup classes behind the
scenes we're gonna like you should
really love each other domestic violence
like kung fu movies though and like when
the kid grows up they're gonna think
that's actual fighting yeah you know
when your parents are doing kung fu in
the living room does a 360 axe kick on
your mom that there's this comedian who
was like it was like you know what went
out my kids like really when my son's
really young I'm gonna show him my dick
once so the rest of his life he thinks
well my dad had the biggest dick in the
world
cuz you know you don't you don't gauge
it you see your first dick you're like
oh [ __ ] dick it's used yeah compared to
yours
but um yeah my parents were amazing and
I'm amazing so so you can you can you
can stay together so jess has a master's
degree dude and and I have a bachelor's
degree hmm and we came we came from a
[ __ ] up upbringing mm-hmm oh wait but
we had good influences that's probably
what happened all right I take it back I
have friends that are on crack and they
came from fucked-up backgrounds don't do
it yeah I had pretty good parents too we
ended up in the same place all right so
for our next story
have you guys heard of gory humor yes I
did
who is this everyone keeps posting it's
a basketball you haven't seen the video
is deep pass away no oh no
keep posting about I don't know happen
so Gordon Hayward had a horrible
accident in the court yeah
as he was playing like five minutes in
on his first game so he as a rookie no
so he bought a Boston Celtics prize free
agent ensign Terry agent and so this is
just like the very first five minutes in
his first game and it was let me show
you guys man you know this is like
watching sports movies 40 times 39 every
time I was like stop watching it so I
don't even know what happened but then
my agent dad sighs kicking in and I'm
like this full Persian I lifted weights
go ahead what no there's a freak
accident
[Applause]
looks like he's breakdancing
it looks like his shoe is just outside
of his what do you have a close-up of
what happened did he just come down and
what happened was he white all right
wait he went up and then his legs went
back like this and he landed like this
he looked like it wasn't me at first so
mind you he's like 200 and some odd
pounds yeah and he falls backwards and
he just hyper extends and he snaps his
ankle yeah watch it again
yeah that's not even the worst and being
injury though Shaun Livingston has the
worst brush oh my god I saw before I saw
the actual clip all I saw was the
reactions of it yeah
damn yeah so it's a freak accident yeah
so he broke his ankle and his leg and so
they're saying that he will not make a
full recovery this seems like he will
not be playing the rest of the few that
make sense
basketball this is magical though with
like all the science and medical help
that these professionals have I wouldn't
be surprised if he plays next year and
this there I know it's Tiger Balm yeah
sack up on the side you meet oh hello
he looks so like a Channing Tatum it's
such because like injuries like that for
like young prospects are career-ending
not career-ending in the sense of life
he will never play in the NBA again but
he will never be she was full potential
yeah like you know what I was going
through his head you know that's the
possibility and by the way like if you
guys don't watch basketball Gordon
Hayward is [ __ ] dope he is like
somebody that was gonna grow into a
beast like everybody's waiting for this
kid this is what's gonna happen they're
gonna make a sports movie about him just
like that one remember that one boxer
guy where he went kind of paralyzed and
we just watched that movie recently we
were doing the oil with miles teller
yeah get to have the head thing in the
hands of stone hands of stone but this
is gonna happen this guy is it's gonna
be like oh my god yeah injury is you
ever gonna play again and he's gonna
train and train and it's gonna be all
motivational [ __ ] he's gonna fight the
odds and he's gonna come over it's gonna
be that [ __ ] spar see but this
is a lesson that you should listen to
your nagging ask mom and drink your milk
lift some weights actually I'm not
weights are gonna help your bum serious
though so I landed one of our buddies
Jacob he's uh he trains a bunch of
professional athletes and he's also the
go-to guy
at least in the West Coast if there are
any prospects in college or high school
they send the athlete to go train with
him first they're not even on the court
but just to restraint the conditioning
to evaluate their body so some people
they're highly skilled but their bodies
aren't able to handle the skill so just
by them lifting weights he can tell okay
this guy yeah he has a crazy duck he's
hella fast if he plays in the NBA zones
are gonna snap because it just doesn't
squat enough he just doesn't have the
to literature to handle his skillset so
stuff like this people like it really
boils down to just having bone density
strong muscles and all that have helped
that though cuz he literally fell back
the living him so you when you go up
mind you he's like really up freak
accident he went up like this he came
down his ankle like this and he felt
back this way so it's just yeah I mean
that's why when you heard that smack
that first math wasn't even his ass it
was his [ __ ] ankle hitting the floor
you know he need a tumeric to be this
needed to drink some tumeric that's
that's all he needed
[ __ ] hipsters big guys aren't supposed
to move like him yeah yeah yeah so like
you guys don't move like that but now
you see a lot of these huge dudes
they're going up go and pull up jump
grabbing the ball you're trying to do al
you dunks all this other [ __ ] and
they're trying to move like [ __ ]
power forwards that's a job for a 5-2
Chinese guy in a circus yeah being tall
is trash man what is the use of tallness
anyway besides the caveman days where
you can use your power to bully people
what is the use or games on the top
shelf yeah I mean yeah reach the Apple
on the tree yeah we got step ladders now
homie we got those [ __ ] things with
the [ __ ] thing like this and you
could just grab them and the t-rex
yeah yeah we got that you pushed that
button and it just grabbed the Apple and
brings it down technology I bet you a
short guy like us we can create at that
because you were the guy that just kept
jumping and trying to get the Apple we
couldn't get the Apple and then we like
we starved to death and died yeah I see
the shot Livi's Livingstone kneecap
terrible no so the Shawn Livingston mind
yeah I mean he wasn't nobody looked at
him like he was gonna be the greatest
but he wasn't like the dope six men like
he was cool he came back he I think he
plays for the Lakers now but his kneecap
started here and it went all the way to
the back of his [ __ ] legs
he was out for years by New Year's it
was all that was one of the worst mba
injuries I've ever seen in my life and
Paul George snapped his leg I don't know
man but there's something to it like you
don't see you never saw these injuries
before growing up so it's very odd that
it happens so often to because they're
getting more strict on the type of like
steroids no it's just it's the level of
game play intense guys are way more
athletic their skill set is crazy it's I
don't think their body it's like to the
brink of human limits almost why are you
guys good because he was kids he made
the same joke I was thinking about it
was like he should have kept his singing
because I were you thinking yo way to
knew it I was trying to make the same
joke girls like [ __ ] is his song singing
because I was holding in my life did me
a peak with the game not too long ago
Sean let me see
Sean Kingston the game and it was a meek
mill right it was yeah yeah yeah yeah
the game forever has beef with everyone
but is like why would you start beef
with the game in this [ __ ] Sean
Kingston I mean you look like [ __ ] an
African Kirby let you get your ass beat
like what's wrong with you he was like
talking mad [ __ ] though he was like [ __ ]
the game you called him a [ __ ] all this
other [ __ ] I'm like dude you're a thug
man in that case then it was for sure
was like an agreed thing like let's get
more publicity out of it yeah five maybe
but you know game was going off on he
was like games games insults on Sean
Kingston cracking me up yeah he's games
really good at talking but he's like a
straight blood though he's like an OG
you know what I mean like it'll [ __ ]
your ass up so anyway so on to our very
last story here we get to finally go to
the one that you wanted which is coffee
sucks I just got you it's gonna be [ __ ]
I love coffee yeah so did Japanese
melted tea to Japanese man named yogi
Tom moshimo tie I love those tires
like 74 years old he invented coffee
made out of entirely of garlic whoops
do you smell like garlic goodnight next
day that was sure it was evil evil
eyebrows that's the [ __ ] Japanese
Colonel Sanders evil Japanese Colonel
garlic Sanders scientist or something no
so 13 years ago he accidentally got into
a fight with a coffee guy he
accidentally made so about 30 years ago
he was cooking some bacon garlic and
then the garlic ended up over his coffee
Oh way overcooked ended up like mashing
it or something and then he drank it he
discovered that I had like a bitter
taste I was really similar to coffee hmm
who the [ __ ] somehow over burns coffee
in the brews I mean God that brews that
[ __ ] while smelling like panties in his
other hand and then when he gets excited
he goes to his robot girlfriend [ __ ]
sex dog oh no and then he took the the
panties and using as a coffee liner in
the [ __ ] disgusting disgusting
Japanese people so yeah here's a
predictable coffee shop right so at that
coffee shop he was like serving coffee
and stuff and that's when you can see
why he does that too he's just
experimenting yeah so then after years
and you're like he ended up retiring and
then years later he started like just
doing a lot of trial and error trying to
make it this garlic coffee work and then
finally now he has perfected it and he's
selling it in just only two places and
it's about two dollars and 80 cents and
orders can be made either going to these
two locations or ordering it by phone
does it have the same effect as coffee
yeah is that caffeine no so that's the
thing this coffee's decaf this coffee is
mainly for people that like want to
drink coffee late at night but still
wanna go sleep or pregnant women who
can't have caffeine interesting so
that's all he's aiming this towards
that's smart because am I good sometimes
I want a little cheesecake but I need
coffee with it and I don't want to drink
caffeine but then like there's decaf
decaf still has pink like I go out for
dinner and I want to eat dessert
oh it's go great with coffee but there I
don't want to [ __ ] be up all night
hot chocolate my do not sweet it's got
to be bitter drink your garlic juice
then lever yeah I will leave the hot
chocolate that one's more better but
yeah bitter I don't eat I've had the
shampoo doddle
that's a hot milk no it's bomb nah I'm
gonna be to Emperor lago impala god oh
yes he now sells them a new little drip
bag oye use pani it is better marketing
but you look like pads over here dude it
does smell like roasted garlic
oh yeah even taste like it hmm the [ __ ]
what I was like stinky tofu smells like
[ __ ] tastes good no it smells like [ __ ]
it tastes like [ __ ] taste it tastes I've
had it monk it tastes like nothing
it's exactly no it does taste bad you
gotta dip it in the soy sauce it's just
this smell [ __ ] with you
no it doesn't taste like Jo has a
fermented sour taste err being
exaggerated oh maybe you need three
[ __ ] times I know now there's three
[ __ ] people
four [ __ ] people look how many times
have you you know and I went to the
source
so did I I had it I've idea for you make
Korean style stinky tofu and just soaked
tofu and kimchi juice cuz that's what
they do they get a spoiled veggies and
then they put the total and a fried that
might be good in my korean-style stinky
tofu
it's not that it's just like the the
fermented flavor that it has is it's
very
dookie dookie licious type of
fermentation is a different bacteria
than that so if yes
gross it's like it's Chinese so harsh I
don't think I've had it I think I liked
it you you all know if you've had it if
you have to think about it then you
haven't had if you if you walk into a
porta potti then you've had it like that
would you
literally mine Vsauce East Asian friends
loved it
well then [ __ ] it let's go after exactly
wait outside I never ate [ __ ] before but
it's pretty much the same thing God hey
guys thanks for watching that last
episode did you love it I know you did
but guess what you can also follow us on
our personal social media accounts with
the links in the description box below
so go follow all of us now to watch more
videos check them out up there
[Music]